previously on the flash tonight we
trapped the reverse-flash in the force
field there's no reason that the
containment system should have failed
I am Hubert Vaughn a completely
different person Oh
hold on someone to this one all right so
imagine there are multiple versions of
earth one where the Nazis won World War
two when where Kennedy was never
assassinated what one were where all of
us are evil been there it sucks
it's time let's bring our boy
it's him
[Music]
hey everybody so we found out how we're
going to see the reverse-flash comeback
this season and it's going to be tied up
in the earth X crossover who knew that
during the Supergirl flash season two
crossover they already teased that idea
a version of earth where the Nazis won
World War two my favorite thing was to
go back and watch that clip right after
they announced it but as with flash
rebirth the speedforce storm it wouldn't
be a rebirth without a reverse flash
rebirth now there's so many different
versions of the reverse flash and
there's so many multiverse locations
that were going to this season that I'll
break down sort of what's going on so
there's a new round of the Justice
League ticket giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so as with all
things this season the reason that promo
is cut that way is is because the
reverse-flash that's coming back is the
reverse-flash that we saw during season
1 so during the crossover you all know
that they're going to earth X it's an
earth in the multiverse where the Nazis
won World War two so things went very
man in the high castle the place that
they're pulling from in the comics for a
lot of this lore is from Justice Society
way way back in the Golden Age then the
more modern great Morrison Multiversity
so you can call it Earth X or earth ten
but the actual team here is called the
new Reich ISM so as part of that they
all have the Nazi versions of characters
with slightly different names the name
of the flash that's a member of this new
Reich is inversion of the Justice League
is called Blitzen so we just say the
Blitzen flash but in the comics she's a
female character and she looks more like
Jay Garrick and the big twist is is that
even though Nazis are bad so everyone's
like oh it's very clearly the good
characters from earth one versus the
evil versions of themselves from Earth X
it's not quite so simple it's sort of a
twist on the idea of red Sun so in red
Sun Superman's pod lands in the Soviet
Union so instead of growing up in Kansas
in upholding the American Way he upholds
the Soviet Union way so communism takes
over the entire world it's the same idea
with the TV show instead of over man
it's over girl although there might be a
version of Superman somewhere on this
world we don't know who the other heroes
are we just know who the main stars of
the crossover are going to be but you've
all probably
this picture of Tom Cavanagh in the
reverse-flash suit with the SS symbol on
his chest so it's like oh maybe this is
meant to be the reverse-flash who's the
Blitzen flash of the crossover so that
raises a whole bunch of other questions
like is this version of the
reverse-flash going to be evil is this
whole team going to be evil what's the
deal because they're all raised to
believe that Nazism is the way but if
he's going to be the Harrison wells of
Earth X that means that he's also eobard
thawne from the distant future meaning
that he has a completely separate agenda
from what these other heroes are doing
so it's almost like he might be hiding
out inside the new Reich ISM team here
with the other team members not really
understanding that he's secretly from
the future but when a lot of you saw
this you're like hey wait a minute
aren't they supposed to be fighting the
evil versions of themselves or at least
the Nazi versions of themselves because
you have to imagine that like this
version of Oliver he would have been
born well after the Nazis won World War
two so he would have been indoctrinated
to think that their way of life was the
proper way so you have to imagine that
in their minds they're just upholding
justice it's just a diversion of Justice
that they've been raised to believe in
is completely twisted
it's a probably a big part of that
during the crossover where you have
characters like Oliver from earth one
trying to explain to his Nazi self Nazis
equal bad but if there aren't any other
twists within the twist like if this is
exactly what's going to be happening and
it's this version of the reverse-flash
then I think part of the reason why they
did that instead of having a Nazi
version of Barry versus our version of
Barry is because what did we just do
last season with Savitt are we had Barry
fighting an evil version of himself
maybe they just didn't want to recycle
that idea so there's still all kinds of
big questions like what's going on with
the rest of the characters on this earth
what happened to Earth X Barry what
happened to Earth X iris because
surprise Nazis do not like people who
aren't white don't speak German and
don't look like they do so it's not just
Jewish people that these Nazis would be
going after all the time they'd be going
after anybody who said anything that
they didn't like like if you go over to
China
they'll censor you if you say things
that the government doesn't like you
have to imagine it'd be a
version of that people that did not
uphold the values that they said were
the correct values even though it's
completely twisted so there's all kinds
of crossover stuff that we can talk
about there they're doing like the most
comic book version of some of the
characters that you've ever seen this is
what Captain Cold looks like during the
crossover it's literally right off of a
comic book cover it's gonna be so
awesome this is what killer frost
costume looks like so Stephen Amell said
that he still had some scenes to film on
it even though most people have wrapped
the crossover they'll probably be a
proper trailer for it in the next couple
of weeks because the episodes will all
drop right at the end of November so I'm
guessing about four weeks out is when
they'll start teasing it a little bit
but even though that version of the
reverse flash is coming back it's not
necessarily the only version of reverse
flash that we'll get hints of this
season but you have to remember that
they're not doubling down on speedsters
so even though we're gonna see a lot of
cool Wally's stuff happening this season
the thinker in those 12 metahumans that
they teased in Episode two those are
really where the focus is going to be so
that all gets back to the speedforce
storm and what's going on at iron
Heights prison so I wouldn't be
surprised that they start filling those
cells and that's how they start
collecting the twelve like Kilgore is
right where he needs to be meaning that
he's probably not going to go anywhere
anytime soon so what I'm expecting from
eobard thawne is that when he comes back
it will be another different version
that's not in the yellow costume like if
we get hints for him it'll probably be a
future version and they'll probably push
a lot of that off to season five so I'm
not expecting a really big reverse-flash
arc besides from the crossover episodes
until season five so it's kind of the
same thing with the Bart Allen tease in
the tornado twins back in episode 1 with
Barry's gibberish like they'll probably
tease all that stuff later this season
but we might actually not see it play
off in a big way until next season
so just remember Cisco thinks that he
tricked the speedforce into letting
Barry go but you can't trick the
speedforce
so this is all going to come back to
haunt them in the back half of the
season and that'll sort of spill into
the big disaster the tease up season 5
that's one of the great things about the
flash is that they always solve their
problems in the season finale in a way
that tees up the MacGuffin of the next
season so we probably won't find out
about that till like the
last couple of episodes but you usually
get some clues before then but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about them bringing back the Harrison
wells version of the reverse-flash
during the crossover really I think it
raises more questions than it answers
because you're like wait a minute are
they just replaying the events of season
1 where he got stuck in the past on this
earth and the same thing is playing out
like he's trying to create his version
of Barrie so that he can steal his speed
and get back to the future or is it some
other big twist the only real version of
the reverse-flash that's technically not
super evil is the version of eobard
thawne from before barry broke his heart
because remember he's this big fanboy of
the flash he spurred then becomes
Barry's big nemesis and it just spirals
out of control from there but they might
wind up simplifying a lot of that for
the crossover like they kind of did that
during season one where Barry's like
tell me why you hate me so much and he
says it doesn't matter anymore like it's
been so long that he's forgotten why he
hates Barry so much but what will happen
is is I have some new Rick and Morty
season 3 and season 4 to post later
tonight so I'll try to get that up as
fast as possible Walking Dead episode 1
drops tomorrow so I'll be doing a video
for that too I have new Game of Thrones
to pose congratulations to Shannon
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for that Bart
Allen scene from episode 1 and you can
click here for that new Justice League
Aquaman trailer to see his new armor
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight